تعرف بانها من اسوا الكوارث الطبيعيه لا
يمكن السيطره عليها تحدث فجاه دون سابق
انذار عاده ما تخلف خسائر بشريه وماديه
تبعا لدرجه قوتها الزلازل ظاهره طبيعيه
مرعبه ترتبط في اذهان الناس بالموت
والدمار فما هو الزلزال وكيف يقع الزلزال
ظاهره كونيه فيزيائيه بالغه التعقيد هو
اهتزاز شديد وحركه مفاجئه في القشره
الارضيه يحدث عند الصدوع بين الصفائح ولكي
نبسط هذا المفهوم تخيل انك تمسك مسطره بين
يديك حاول ثنيها تدريجيا ستشعر بنوع من
المقاومه عند الجانبين وستلاحظ ان المسطره
تصعد من المنتصف مع تصاعد المقاومه حتى
تنكسر المسطره من المنتصف يرتفع طرف
المنتصف فيها للاعلى ويهبط طرفاها للاسفل
بق وبسرعه هكذا يحدث الزلزال يزيد الضغط
على القشره الارضيه تدريجيا الى ان تنكسر
الصفائح الارضيه وتهتز الارض تنتقل الطاقه
الناتجه عن الزلزال عبر الارض على شكله
اهتزازات تعرف باسم الموجات الزلزاليه لكن
هل من توابع الزلزال يتبع الزلزال في
الغالب هزات ارضيه اقل شده من الهزه
الرئيسيه تنتج عن التغير المفاجئ في
الاجهاد الذي يحدث داخل وبين الصخور
والاطلاق السابق للضغط الناجم عن الزلزال
الرئيس وتحدث الهزات الارتداديه للصخور
الواقعه بالقرب من مركز الزلازل او على
طول الصدى الذي كان حدث عليه الزلزال
الرئيس ويمكن ان يستمر حدوثها لفترات
طويله قد تصل لعقود او قرون مثل التتابع
الناتج عن زلزال نيو مدريد المستمر حتى
يومنا الحل